[Música]
hablamos de salud en derecho américa de
france24 y ya está conmigo en el estudio
más romeros a la mar bienvenida feliz
mañana de martes vamos a recuperar un
hito en la historia de la ciencia porque
por supuesto vale la pena resaltarlo en
nuestro espacio de salud porque por
primera vez el euro secuenciar el genoma
humano de una manera completa mar así es
raúl muy buenos días es una noticia que
vimos el viernes pero que vamos a
recuperar ahora porque podremos
desarrollarla más después con una de las
autoras del estudio hagamos un resumen
rápido el genoma es la secuencia total
del material genético de los humanos es
como una especie de libro libro de
instrucciones del cual ahora tenemos el
índice hasta ahora se tenía el 92 por
ciento de este genoma se terminó de
secuenciar el 8 por ciento que faltaba
en ese 8 por ciento que faltaba se han
encontrado aproximadamente unos 100
genes codificantes eso significa que son
genes que producen una proteína y que la
proteína es el lenguaje que entiende el
cuerpo para luego desarrollar una
función o una característica también se
encontraron dos mil genes que deberán
estudiarse con más detalle para saber si
cumplen alguna función y si es así cuál
es y también 2 millones aproximadamente
de variantes genéticas que hasta ahora
se desconocían es decir 2 millones de
lugares en esta secuencia genética donde
el genoma puede variar de persona a
persona porque tan relevante ese
descubrimiento marc ahora lo profundo de
haremos más como decíamos pero
básicamente el genoma es una especie de
enciclopedia gigante que describe cómo
somos cómo funcionamos entonces pre para
empezar resulta abrir la puerta a
entender mejor esa enciclopedia o esa es
el libro de instrucciones no lugar
además también pues los lugares donde
faltaba más información son los lugares
del cromosoma llamados telómeros y
centrómeros y esos lugares están
relacionados con algunos procesos sobre
el cual es ahora mismo hay muchos
interrogantes por ejemplo el
envejecimiento el cáncer malformaciones
congénitas además de era una de las
normas del zapato que había en la
ciencia porque desde 1990 se está
intentando secuenciar este genoma desde
inicios de los 2000 nos habíamos quedado
en ese 92 por ciento entonces pues claro
era una incógnita que seguía flotando
ahí y además pues es que secuenciar el
genoma es un trabajo muy muy difícil
para que nos hagamos una idea vamos a
hacer abc de que es este genoma tenemos
como este cromosoma tenemos 23 pares hay
46 cromosomas así que se agrupan en 23
pares estos cromosomas están formados
por unas proteínas que le dan estructura
y luego por un hilo larguísimo de adn de
codificación genética que se hilos de
esa doble hélice que tenemos pues en
nuestra cabeza cuando pensamos en el adn
en este hilo hay una secuencia de
moléculas hay 4 ag c&t que se emparejan
con el del frente haciendo esa escalera
que tenemos como decíamos en la imagen
mental de lo que es el adn y
determinadas combinaciones de esas
moléculas hacen los genes no para
hacernos una idea hay 3500 3.055 perdón
millones de pares de letras si lees
escribiéramos todas seguidas tendríamos
suficiente información para llenar el
equivalente a cuatro mil copias del
quijote de la mancha' dios mío mar bueno
eso vamos entonces a seguir
profundizando con nuestra segunda
invitada del día
[Música]
y como lo estábamos conversando con más
romero sala pues vamos a hablar con una
de las coautoras de este estudio del
genoma humano jahan y el asunto
estudiante de doctorado de quinto año en
la universidad de california
está bajo la supervisión de la doctora
megan denise gracias de nela por estar
con nosotros en este espacio de salud de
directo o américa mar muchos muy buenos
días pero hay muchas gracias por
acompañarnos quería recalcar que es de
la unidad de california davis para
exactamente si ahí se me olvidó ese
ático mal gracias por por complementarlo
pues daniela un gusto o tenerla con
nosotros en directo américa como ya se
lo decía y le quiero preguntar entonces
para tener una idea general cuáles
importancia de haber completado esta
secuencia del genoma humano
sí muchas gracias por tenerme aquí en
esta entrevista en su programa este es
un hito histórico para la ciencia
nos demoramos desde la primera el
proyecto del genoma humano en el 2001
nos demoramos 20 años en poder finalizar
completamente la secuencia del genoma
humano y ese 8% que mencionaba mal que
ahora que que no conocíamos ahora por
fin se abre a la ciencia a la comunidad
científica para poder estudiar cuál es
su rol biológico
celular pero también su impacto en lo
que es la evolución humana y la salud
quería preguntarle por qué había sido
tan difícil hasta ahora encontrar ese 8%
qué características tienen esas partes
que ahora se han rellenado de
información para que tardaremos tantos
años en entender que se escondía ahí
si efectivamente fue estas partes fueron
muy difíciles de secuenciar porque son
las partes más complejas del genoma en
el sentido de que contienen muchas
secuencias repetidas como mencionaba
marx los centros de los los telómeros y
otras partes además de esas y estas
secuencias repetidas son muy difíciles
de ensamblar o de reconstruir porque
sucede lo mismo que pasa como cuando uno
está armando un puzzle cuando uno tiene
un puzzle tiene partes en donde hay
muchos colores distintos objetos
diferentes y eso hace que sea más fácil
poder reconstruir la imagen original
pero estas partes y faltaban son el
equivalente al cielo donde están las
nubes o patrones repetidos quien cuesta
mucho poder reconstruir cuál era la
imagen original del puzzle y en el caso
de esta investigación reconstruir la
secuencia original del genoma y lo
pudieron completar finalmente a daniela
pero cuando hablamos de esa secuencia
del adn a qué nos referimos realmente
como el proceso
todo este genoma humano
y en el adn se compone principalmente de
estas cuatro moléculas
representadas en las letras de ese eje
dependiendo del orden en que estas
letras se encuentren pueden codificar
para distintos tipos de rasgos humanos
entonces el proceso de secuenciación lo
que llamamos significa determinar
exactamente el orden de estas secuencias
para poder predecir cuál es el rasgo al
que por el que codifican el proceso de
lectura sin embargo es un proceso
complejo lo ideal se dirige a tomar en
dna y poder de adn y poder leerlo de
principio a fin sin problemas pero esta
tecnología no existe entonces lo que los
científicos hacemos es tomar el adn que
sea el conjunto de estas letras a psg y
cortarlas en pequeños pedacitos y
leerlas las en máquinas que son capaces
de procesar las detectan pequeños
verdades ante quienes piezas y luego
viene el proceso de reconstrucción que
se hace de manera computacional y
algunas de estas zonas que estábamos
diciendo que quedaban todavía sin leer
en un momento se habían llegado a
denominar como adn basura esto parece
que puede cambiar nuestra percepción de
que realmente fuera adn que no servía
para nada o que hemos aprendido respecto
a esta calificación casi despectiva de
esos pobres partes de adn
sí es cierto esa idea del adn basura que
se estableció décadas atrás de alguna
manera quedó en el inconsciente
colectivo pero esa idea se ha ido
contrarrestando básicamente se ha
encontrado que no es no es verdad y en
las últimas décadas y con este avance ya
finalmente podemos vamos a poder
establecer completamente el rol que
juegan pero si sabemos que todas estas
zonas son fundamentales en términos de
la estructura del adn
y esta estructura es fundamental en
distintos procesos celulares como los
procesos de reproducción celular que
están asociados con lo mencionaba al
cáncer oa otros tipos de enfermedades de
origen genético
entonces definitivamente esa idea con
este con este hito es que la atrás y
vamos a poder realmente entender cuál es
su rol si daniela y precisamente ahí
quería llegar porque cuáles son entonces
los aportes a la comunidad científica de
nuestra salud de haber completado
finalmente este genoma podemos entender
mejor varias enfermedades e incluso
encontrar curas ellas teniendo
completado ya este genoma
si este genoma es además de un hito
histórico es una herramienta para la
comunidad científica se usa este genoma
completo se va a utilizar como un punto
de referencia para poder contrarrestar
las variantes genéticas en la población
humana y a partir de eso establecer cuál
es su rol en la evolución y la salud
entonces si bien este juguito también es
una herramienta que la comunidad
científica ahora va a utilizar y eso es
algo que el consorcio telómero a
telómero trabajó muy arduamente
trabajamos muy arduamente para generar
muchos recursos para la comunidad
científica y ahora va a poder por fin
responder cuál es el rol de estas del
genoma completo en
los rasgos humanos y las enfermedades
claro para dar un poco de contexto
también este genoma que se ha
secuenciado sólo uno que se usa como
marco de referencia luego para todas
estas investigaciones
queríamos preguntarle si podría explicar
por qué sólo un genoma sirve de
referencia para tanta información y si
deberíamos ahora secuenciar nuevos genes
o realmente no es una información a
hacer este secuenciación completa que es
tanto trabajo no vale la pena en verdad
es un excelente punto y esa es la razón
por la que utilizamos sólo un genoma en
tema técnico nos costó 20 años
secuenciar un genoma completo y lo ideal
es tener mucha información con genomas
completos de muchas personas y eso es lo
que nos daría la mayor cantidad de
información y en este sentido el escrito
científico también generó a través del
consorcio telómero telómero se generaron
muchos recursos expertise y software
necesario para poder procesar el genoma
humano a partir de este hito el objetivo
es secuenciar cientos de personas y eso
ya está en el proceso y en los próximos
años vamos a poder ver esos avances
científicos así es daniela y hablando de
avances científicos y de científicos le
quería preguntar cómo fue el proceso de
trabajar con un centenar de científicos
de muchas partes del mundo y además que
se siente usted cómo se sintió mejor
dicho usted como latinoamericana de
haber sido parte de todo esto hacer
parte historia y pues nada menos que ya
terminar de completar el genoma humano
y el proceso fue un proceso muy
reconfortante el consorcio telonero
telómero está conformado por cientos de
científicos que trabajaron muy
arduamente durante la pandemia y de
manera completamente remota
coordinándonos a través de la ínsula y
y con el objetivo conjunto de poder
lograr este hito científico
y como latina me sentía muy honrada
porque cuando especie de estudiar
biología estaba el proyecto del genoma
humano que es en ella como algo tan
lejano y ahora logré eso se parte de
este maravilloso
hito para la ciencia y espero aquí en un
futuro más latinas y más hispanas se
puedan sumar a este tipo de consorcios
así es abrir puertas para todos los que
vendrán detrás también como decíamos
apenas empezamos a tener este mapa
completo o este índice podemos buscar
muchísimas comparaciones poéticas para
hablar de este momento no pero ahora
cuál es el siguiente paso que viene
ahora que tenemos este 100% de genoma
secuenciado
el siguiente paso es que la comunidad
científica tome este genoma y cada uno a
través de sus diferentes
experiencias y
conocimientos pueda responder cómo está
este genoma en su totalidad puede
impactar distintas enfermedades o
distintos rasgos en la ciencia es un
trabajo colaborativo de miles de
millones de personas trabajando a lo
largo del
mundo para poder responder
cuál es la función del genoma y en ese
sentido ahora lo que viene es que la
comunidad de este negocio no va para
responder a distintas preguntas
científicas y además se vienen nuevos
avances revolucionarios en términos
tener nuevos genomas como les mencionaba
completas quizás cientos en los próximos
años que también nos van a proporcionar
mucha más información sobre la biología
celular el genoma la evolución y la
salud pues muchísimas gracias por toda
esta información la verdad es que para
nosotros es un honor también poder
contar con autores de los propios
estudios de los que hablamos de aquí
cada día para entender mejor las
implicaciones que tienen todos estos
avances científicos así es daniela
gracias una vez más por estar con
nosotros en directo américa de france 24
como lo dijo marc para nosotros ha sido
y es siempre un honor tener a personas
como usted además que nos orgullece
tenerlos y pues que trabajen para el
bien de la humanidad y para evolucionar
en nuestra nuestra salud gracias daniel
a
muchas gracias estábamos conversando
entonces marc como ya lo vieron todos
nuestros televidentes con daniela soto
como autora del estudio del genoma
humano estudiante de doctorado el quinto
año en la universidad de california
davis bajo la supervisión de la doctora
megan denise nosotros continuamos esto
es directo américa que s con nosotras
[Música]